The probability function which here now is expressed as a
map again using map rotation right colon arrows
when you see these characters, this is this
is a map.
the probability function will map
the random variable
which is it which is itself a representation of
events
It will map.
The random variable the values in random variable these
ones and zeros.
to the set
of values between 0 and 1
Inclusive of zero, so this is what we call a
closed interval. Which means
Any value on X can take on any number from 0 to
1.
And that's what probability is Right probability. We said is a
number between 0 1 so probably the outcome of maybe I
used the word outcome the result of a probability function.
Is probability which we set as
a number between 0 and 1?
Now let me talk. Let me show you that notation. I
told you about which means something but it is
not explicit.
So you might see something that looks like this.
This is read the probability that X.
Will be equal to 1.
What this really means?
or this is a short hand notation for
this over here.
We are saying what is the probability of
the set
notice the curly brackets
So we have the outermost parentheses because the outermost parentheses.
Means that P is a function, which is what we said.
P is a function. Yes probability is a function. The probability
function is a function.
Which means it will take.
An element and give you another value.
So it will take a set.
the set has one element a
such that this vertical bar means such that.
When we plug in a inside X it
gives us one.
Let me say let me say that again.
What is the probability?
Of the set that contains a such that
when we take that when we take a plug it
into X we get one.
now a is an element in capital a
So it's the outcome of the event a what did we say a is?
head to heads Tails tails
What is that element?
Then when you put inside X will give you one.
What is the element when you put inside X will make
it 1?
It's heads.
If you put heads the outcome heads.
Inside the function X you will get a one.
now based on your background and
Why you are taking this course?
This could either be relevant or not.
at a later point
At a later point in time when you've covered much of this
course, this might be relevant. But when
you watch the subsequent videos in this
course
And should you wonder what this notation
is and how our random variables related to
events?
You may want to come back to this video.